la justice a donné son feu vert à la
réouverture de l'enquêté sur l'affairé
grégory des analyses génétiques vont
donc être effectués sur le timbre d'une
lettre envoyée par le corbeau
de nouveaux éléments qui pourraient
conduire sur la piste de celui qui a
assassiné le petit garçon clément
weill-raynal benoît véran la décision de
la cour d'appel de dijon est une
première dans l'histoire judiciaire la
chambre d'accusation a en effet estimé
que le progrès scientifique constitue en
soi un élément nouveau permettant la
réouverture d'une enquête qu'il était
définitivement close
en l'occurrence celle de l' affaire
grégory en conséquence la chambre
d'accusation ordonne qu'une recherche d'
à dn soit effectuée sous le timbre d'une
lettre envoyée par un mystérieux corbeau
aux parents du petit grégory en 1983
soit plus de 18 mois avant l'assassinât
de l'enfant
si nous pouvons en effet identifié le
corbeau scripteur du printemps 1983
nous aurons des éléments pour identifier
le corbeau assassins de l'automne 1984
mais ses personnages peuvent être
différents alors ça peut être le même
personnage
il y aura les difficultés que nous
connaissons et nous voulons continuer
cette procédure avec beaucoup de calme
de sérénité
seize ans après l'assassinât du petit
grégory la sphère pourrait-elle être
relancée et le terrible secret de la
vologne enfin percer
aujourd'hui les paons je veux tu oublié
tous les protagonistes du drame quittait
le village
seuls les parents de grégory espère
encore découvrir la vérité c'est
christine villemin elle-même et son mari
jean marie qui ont été à l'origine à la
fin du mois de novembre 1990
de cette demande de faisabilité pour
déterminer si oui ou non les progrès de
la science pouvait amener attentes et
d'espérer un jour approcher la vérité
parce que l'assassinât d'un petit garçon
de 4 ans ne peut pas rester impuni
moi je crains qu'on rallume les passions
sans arriver à la vérité
et n'oublions pas qu'en ce qui
concernait famille villemin les familles
laroche et tous les protagonistes
ils ont aujourd'hui pris de l'âge c'est
bastien qui a vu son enfant son père
assassiné devant ses yeux
sébastien larouche sébastien laroche a
aujourd'hui 15 ans lucile à 19 ans les
enfants villemin ont grandi les odeurs
envie demain ce qui bon tous les
protagonistes ont grandi ce que je
crains c'est de rallumer les patients
sans atteindre la vérité mais la chambre
d'accusation estimé que cette recherche
de la vérité mérite est la réouverture
du dossier
les résultats de l'expertisé pourrait
être connu dès le mois de septembre